well comedian dave chappelle uh was
attacked on stage last night in los
angeles it's a horrendous example of how
comedy is coming under threat to the
point that performers are literally now
in fear of their lives joining me now is
wrestling superstar and tv host harris
whose new book just taurus is storming
the charts taurus and a cracking reed
along with stand-up british comedian
dame baptiste welcome to both of you uh
taurus let me start with you um
we saw what happened at the oscars
and in a way i could see how that
happened because there was history
between chris rock and will smith will
smith i think misconstrued that chris
rock was deliberately taunting his wife
about her medical condition and so on
it's a bar and brawl that goes on up and
down the country all the time this is
much more sinister it seems to me
because whoever did this to dave
chappelle whoever does dave chappelle i
think probably doesn't know him probably
is reacting to all the debate about his
comedy about his his jokes about the
trans community and that to me is on a
different level what's your view
no i'm and i rarely disagree with you
about anything but uh no the thing that
happened to chris rock was just as worse
uh if
it was the dinner belt because when
will smith did that he being who he is
in the position he is
he just said hey this is what you do
when you don't like what they say
because he had no consequences
he wasn't dragged off by security and
thrown out and embarrassed and
humiliated he literally went back to his
seat and then talked more trash
so when when people see this especially
the lower end of our society and they're
thinking how can i that guy didn't go to
the comedy show and he wasn't sitting
there going and he heard a joke that he
was so offended that he jumped up and he
went there premeditated he had a weapon
he was there because two things were
going to happen one he was going to get
a lot of attention he was going to be on
the news and he'd be able to say
whatever political thing he wanted to
say and how comedy is this and that the
only thing he didn't count on was that
dave chappelle works out he's shredded
like a julian salad he hangs out with
busta rhymes who's like a biscuit away
from 300 pounds and he's got a really
serious security team as snoop's former
bodyguard i had a very same similar
situation and i left the guy just as
twisted so he got some real life
consequences so hopefully all the woke
that see that we can make a statement by
going after comedians uh they'll think
twice because this is what happens in
the real world well you know what tyler
said about that yeah i'll say you've
actually you've actually made me think
twice about what you just said
uh you've made me rethink what i think
about the will smith chris rock thing
because i was a little bit not defensive
of will spit but i was understanding but
in terms of the precedent that it's set
i think you make a very good point that
guy may well have been inspired by
what's happened at the oscars and that
may well now be parroted across america
and other countries let me bring in uh
dane baptiste dane
you're a stand-up comedian you perform
in front of audience all the time they
can get raucous they can get noisy you
can get hecklers but when you see
somebody of dave chappelle's statue i
think he's one of the great comedians in
the world today if not of all time
you see someone like him attacked by
somebody with a replica gun which had a
spring up knife in it and literally
could have killed him
what did that what made you
think about that what's your view about
that what happens now next time you go
out in front of an audience um i mean
whatever happens to me will remain
exactly the same appears if someone uh
crosses the boundary of approaching me
on stage it no longer is the paradigm of
a comedian and audience what you're
dealing with then is a potential
belligerent or assailant and me as a
civilian having the right to defend
myself um with that being said i am not
somebody who
is adverse to the plight of the trans
community or the transgender community
but at the same time i think anyone who
has taken the time to build context of
dave chappelle and his narrative would
understand that he has made it a point
of principle uh artistic principle to
hold america and the western
civilization under a microscope and
examine various groups and i think he
does that from the position of fool and
so it's very worrying that people will
resort to violence especially uh with
deadly weapons and again uh i am pain
too but i do agree with yourself and
tyrus in terms of the fact that this may
be a present that's been set by will
smith's actions which has encouraged
people to believe that they are able to
use physical force in order to quote a
narrative they don't necessarily agree
with and um i think it's probably the
most extreme and potentially most lethal
form of censorship that exists in our
society with that being said i want to
thank you for unblocking me on twitter
as well
it was kind of funny actually i'm doing
a show called piers morgan uncensored
and dame before he came on pointed out
to our producers i blocked him on
twitter so i had to uncancel you dane
which is what we do on this show if you
are formally on cancel we're back in
twitter love to with each other let me
bring taurus back in taurus we've seen
some weird stuff going on this we saw
the chris rock thing we saw this thing
last night with dave chappelle we also
saw you know random strangers on planes
baiting mike tyson it's like it happened
again yesterday with somebody else with
mike tyson what is going on here are
people just going slightly mad because
of a pandemic because of other issues do
you feel there's a rising tension
amongst the populace or am i
overthinking it
no unfortunate you're not overthinking
it but you're
you're giving them too much credit this
comes down to
fame seeking attention seeking and
whatever message they want to get out
it's just like here's the thing with the
thing with dave chappelle real quickly
groups are coming out saying this is
what happens when you use words that
hurt people's feelings so it was dave
chappelle's fault it was like basically
saying how were you dressed when he
attacked you instead of owning the fact
that there is never a good reason if
someone says something you don't like
you never get it there's no reason to
put hands on him you just don't watch
him anymore the thing with mike tyson is
the guy who got into it mike tyson got
spread he goes all over his twitter is
up he's getting all kinds of attention
so you know they're seeing they're
targeting celebrities especially um
looks like they're targeting black
celebrities like brothers we getting
targeted because anything we do to them
they end up being the victim
yeah but dane um in terms of comedy
itself is there a line you know people
say to me well pears morgan uncensored
is there a line you won't cross on the
show are the things guests could say are
there jokes they could tell which would
cross the line i think there is a line i
don't think anything is acceptable you
incite you know death threats against
people if you incite violence against
people i think that crosses the line but
as a comedian you know you reference
their dave chappelle's material about
the trans community i don't think he
does it from a place of hate at all i
don't think he's transphobic i think
he's talking about issues that have been
raised very publicly in the trans world
which i think should be openly debated
but you know are you suggesting that in
some way when you say that that there
are things that are off limits in terms
of topics rather than direct threats of
violence
um i don't think there should be any
topic that's necessarily off the table
for a comedian but i think it's
important for people to remember that as
a comedian you are taking the position
arguably overfall so to speak and so um
and as an artist your work is always
dynamic so even if dave chappelle does
make a statement that does appear to be
incendiary towards a particular minority
group that doesn't necessarily mean that
he's condemning them or he's ratifying
any violence or marginalization of said
group he is always open to be able to go
back and revisit his material with the
more uh knowledge and information he
receives from that particular group but
i think the problem is is that we are
now living in a time where um the
bipartisan political spectrum has failed
us and we're not able to find ideologues
and politicians that we can necessarily
trust there's a lot of duplicity amongst
that so people look to other uh uh
people with platforms and unfortunately
as a result of which because comedians
and comedy as an art form does tend to
feature as an honest form of politics it
means that we are now being singled out
as a focal point so anybody's kind of
angst right issues uh taurus i don't let
you go without giving you a plug for
your book which is roaring up the charts
on amazon i saw your tweet today
congratulations on that very quickly
what's the title of the book and what's
it about
uh the name of the book is just tyrus a
memoir and it's just basically about uh
all the jobs i've had been fired from so
it's a lot of stories of how you take
failure and uh you turn it into
something else and how you transition
from one to the other and um you know
that's my story i'm sticking to it well
it's uh it's storming the charts i can't
wait to read it great to have you on the
show thank you very much teresa always a
pleasure sir it's an honor and a
blessing back the honor is mine and
thank you also today
thank you for having me pierce